fired minneapolis police officer derrick
chauvin will be sentenced for the murder
of george floyd this afternoon
the prosecution is asking for 30 years
in prison
chauvin's defense team is asking for
probation and no more jail time
minnesota's sentencing guidelines
recommend at least 12
and a half years in prison jamie yukis
has more on today's sentencing hearing
the last time the public saw derrick
chauvin he was being led away in
handcuffs
after a jury found him guilty on all
counts for the murder of george floyd
today he'll return to court for his
sentencing by judge peter cahill
cbs news legal analyst ricky clemen says
cahill will examine arguments from the
prosecution
and the defense victim impact statements
a pre-sentence investigation into
chauvin's past
and any statement chauvin might make
before delivering his sentence
how likely is it that derek chovan would
face the maximum sentence
we have to understand what the maximum
sentence under the law
is which is 40 years i would frankly be
surprised if he got any less than 20
but i've been surprised before don
samuels is a former minneapolis council
member from the city's north side
he hopes the chauvin sentencing will
close the loop on a painful cycle
that includes a spike in crime and
reduction in police staffing
people are just trying to decide do we
support that
sentiment and say let's get rid of all
police or do we
find some other way let's get hard on
crime we're saying
you have you can do both you can have a
fair and just police
force and you can also have enough
police officers because
we can't tell our city to be destroyed
before chauvin is sentenced he does have
the opportunity to address the court
we're not sure if he's going to do that
but if he does it's unlikely to change
judge cahill's position
that's because he's had months to review
all the testimony
and evidence in this case anthony jamie
thank you and stay with cbs news for
continuing coverage from minneapolis
we will bring you a special report when
chauvin is sentenced
this afternoon